hey guys this is chris kohler four-game
life we're down here at the game
developers conference and right now
we're going to go check out one of the
hottest upcoming titles for xbox 360 to
human we're going to talk with its
director dennis Dayak and i'm actually
going to get hands-on so come along with
me to human you play the role of Baldr
the cybernetic God charged with the
defense of mankind against an army
machines trying to wipe you out and it's
a game that's really a fusion of action
and RPG with a lot of detailed
compelling story the roots of Norse
mythology are actually in this story and
that mankind goes through these cycles
of a great technology growth and then
through Armageddon's and reverts back
and it just goes into the cycles so and
imagine that this is a long-forgotten
futuristic pass where mankind was really
advanced but gets caught into these warm
games against machines and other and you
know other other territories vying for
power and this is the roots of Norse
mythology so tell me about you know I'm
a big fan of eternal darkness run of
Silicon Knights games for the Gamecube
yes as an internal darkness span what is
there in to human that's going to grab
me well I think I think the story is
equally as compelling it's thoughtful
it's it's not your typical it's not your
typical fare I'm a big believer in a lot
of people say you know video game
stories can't be as good as other genres
I I fight that tooth and nail I i love
you know books like altered carbon or
Hyperion are considered Philebus those
type of deep deep deeply researched and
well thought science fiction that's what
we're trying to tell here and I think if
gamers like the deep store in eternal
darkness still like this as well we've
also combined it with action and deep
role-playing elements was a unique
combination looked at eternal darkness
on the surface lot of people thought it
was like resident evil but when he
played it was nothing like resident evil
into human it may look like devil may
cry or got a war
it's nothing like that a matter of fact
there's nothing like even the a blower a
world of warcraft it's a combination of
both of those things which is very
unique in itself when you create
something new it's very difficult for
people to digest so the way I like to
describe it here and as I've described
it tonight is we're standing on the
shoulders of giants I'm just trying to
describe a waste of paper can comprehend
the only way to really see to humans to
sit down and play it yourself we believe
that video games are the eighth art form
and we're we're trying to use you know
the language of cinematography to tell
the game we're doing seamless cuts
there's never any load times in the game
you know we've got a lot of great
technology eight lights / characters
four times anti-aliasing 720p all those
kind of things that people can play in a
fast action seamlessly integrated deep
storyline type of game so we think all
those elements together will create
something that's no greater than some of
the parts its parts and give you an
experience that you know is very
compelling and very unusual well Dennis
I am really looking forward to you kumin
as you know so I can't wait for this
this demo to finally come out in the
game so but thank you very much for
being here with all my pleasure thanks
for having me
you